hello everybody so Secretary of Pompeo
and I are here today to talk about the
president's new executive order and
after that we'd be happy to take a few
questions
so today the president signed a new
executive order which underscores his
decisive leadership in fighting fighting
global terrorism this administration is
intensified our counterterrorism
sanctions effort we've designated more
than 230 individuals and entities in
2018 the most designation of any year in
the last 15 years the new executive
order modernizing sanctions to combat
terrorism which was signed today greatly
enhances our ability to identify
sanction and deter perpetrators of
terrorism worldwide among other
provisions the EO allows the US
government to better target terrorist
group leaders provides new tools to
pursue individuals who participate in
terrorist training authorizes secondary
sanctions on foreign financial
institutions that have knowingly
conducted or facilitated significant
financial transactions with sanctions
persons and targets those actors for on
behalf of specially designated global
terrorists utilizing this new executive
order today Treasury sanctioned over two
dozen individuals and entities from 11
terrorist group specifically we have
leaders operative in finance ears from
over 11 terror organizations including
Iran's could forces Thomas Isis al Qaeda
and their affiliates the government has
taken more action than we ever have
before
the u.s. is Treasury is enhancing our
efforts deny terrorists access to the US
financial system we will continue to
make sure that the security of the
United States and to protect innocent
people from becoming victims of
terrorist attacks
Thank You Steven today's executive order
marks the most significant update to
counterterrorism sanctions authorities
since September of 2001 it significantly
expands authorities to target terrorists
and those who finance their activities
specifically today's action amends
executive order 13224 by adding clauses
that allow the department's of State and
Treasury to first directly target
leaders of terrorist groups and their
associated entities without having to
tie terrorist leaders to specific acts
second it more effectively and
efficiently targets individuals and
entities who participate in terrorist
training and provides new authorities to
impose sanctions on foreign financial
institutions institutions that knowingly
do business with terrorists the Trump
administration has already used existing
sanctions authorities more aggressively
than any administration before us and
now we're immediately putting these new
authorities to good use a secretary
marushin said today the Department of
State announces the designation of 12
terrorist leaders they include Isis wali
of Iraq and former mayor of improvised
explosive devices for senior members of
Hezbollah jihad Council and leaders from
Hamas Palestinian Islamic Jihad Isis
Philippines Isis West Africa and TTP in
Pakistan further we're announcing the
designation of harass Aldean an al-qaida
village jihadist group in Syria as a
specially designated global terrorist
entity as these actions show today is
executive order by president from adds
further muscle to US counterterrorism
efforts it will help us to ensure that
the deadly attacks of September 11th
that occurred 18 years ago this week are
never repeated on American soil
never at this time secretaries are happy
to take a couple questions on this topic
leave the White House because he
disagreed with you in particular over
toxins intelligent so last night the
president asked for emboss ambassador
Bolton's resignation as I understand it
it was received this morning was it
because of this disagreement I'll leave
to the President to talk about the
reasons he made the decision but but I
would say this the president's entitled
to the staff that he wants and at any
moment this is a staff person who works
directly for the president of States and
he should have people he trusted values
and whose efforts and judgments benefit
him and delivering American foreign
policy it's what as cabinet members
secretary mooch and I try and do each
and every day and when the president
makes a decision like this the workings
of how this all goes we we all give our
candid finish there were many times
ambassador bolt and I disagree that's to
be sure but that's true for lots of lots
of people who with who might interact my
mission set is always to make sure as I
run the Department of State is to
deliver America's diplomacy and to work
with the team whether it's a Treasury or
the president's staff to make sure we
get good outcomes I I don't I don't I
know everyone's talked about this for an
awfully long time there were definitely
places that ambassador and I bolt and I
had different views about how we should
proceed
I would say Secretary of Pompeo and
myself and the president are completely
aligned on our maximum pressure campaign
I think you know we've done more
sanctions on Iran and anybody and it's
absolutely working now the president has
made clear he's happy to take a meeting
with no preconditions but we are
maintaining the maximum pressure
campaign you foresee a meeting between
President Trump and the Iranian leader
later this month surrounding the United
Nations sure support that do you support
the president's made very clear he's
prepared to meet with no preconditions
this briefing Bolton was on the guidance
to be here so for YouTube blindsided by
what occurred today but he's no longer
with the administration was it news to
you today since last night you were
hoping to be here I'm never surprised
would say the same thing we work very
closely with the president United States
we I think we have a pretty good
understanding of how he's thinking about
things I think you'd agree Stephen and
nearly all times and so you know we are
our mission our missions that's not to
talk about these inner workings in the
palace intrigue that I know you are so
curious about but but rather to talk
about the things that matter to American
foreign policy
I just add people who new should know
and don't get into you know the
administrative things of a notice went
out because Syria we reported on Syria
and the refugee camps last night I
didn't hear was there and he talked
about how these refugee camps Isis
fighters are blending in there's
children dancing around the ISIS fled
are you concerned about these refugee
camps becoming a breeding ground a
training ground for terrorists for Isis
fighters so there's a long history of
just exactly what you're describing
camps in Iraq camps other places where
our prisoners were detained and
extremist elements breeding in those
places but we've been working diligently
on this we have conducted enormous
operations against Isis even after the
fall of the Caliphate as recently as the
last handful of days we are very focused
on this the success that we had moving
down the Euphrates River Valley that our
Department of Defense led with the SDF
forces was truly remarkable we will not
take our eye off the ball ensuring that
whether it's Isis or other radical
Islamic extremist groups continue to be
under pressure from the United States of
America and that would include in these
camps that you're referring to
[Music]
I'll leave that to them to the White
House to talk about other than to say I
think President Trump I watched his
campaign I've now worked with him first
as CIA director and now a Secretary of
State someone asked what would the
policy be different absent any
individual being here these have been
the president's policies we give him our
best wisdom we share with him our
understanding when I was intelligence
director we did our best to make sure he
had the facts and data available so he
could make good decisions but I don't
think any lead around the world should
make any assumption that because some
one of us two parts that the president
Trump's foreign policy will change in a
material way the one thing I would just
say follow-up because the president's
been very clear on this the president's
view of the Iraq war and ambassador
Bolton's was very different the
president's made sure way in the back
yes me
so we're looking forward to our meeting
with foreign minister of art here just a
little bit we're going to talk about the
progress that's been made which has been
substantial and real and material and
has made America more secure but at the
same time we know there's still work to
do we're going to talk about how best we
can jointly deliver that we are deeply
appreciative of what the President of
Mexico and the Foreign Minister have
done to increase the capacity to deter
migration into the United States and you
can see the numbers have have improved
substantially but we also know it needs
to be sustained be we've still got real
work to do trying to keep up the
pressure engine as well in the picture
and we know that that's the Dark
Continent President Trump is agree on
many things and require the regardless
to Venezuela
what can we expect now with the
departure of the I think you know the
the Treasury Department and the State
Department have been incredibly active
on sanctions everything we do is in
consultation with the State Department
again we have a massive sanctions
program that's working but I would just
add we are concerned about the people
there and what's going on the Amanah
terian crisis and I know the Secretary
has worked with their neighbors
extensively absolutely not that's the
most ridiculous question I've ever heard
let me just say the national security
team which is what you asked consists of
the national security Iser the secretary
of defense the secretary
you
I'm sorry I said well we'll take one
under which administration was this
source Fernand is there currently an
investigation into how his identity got
leads the media yeah I've seen that
reporting the reporting is materially
inaccurate and you should know I as the
former CIA director I don't talk about
things like this very often it is only
the occasions when there's something
that I think puts people at risk or the
reporting is so egregious as to create
enormous risk to the United States of
America that I even comment in the way
that I just did and I won't say anything
more about it I know the CIA put out a
statement suffice to say that the the
reporting there is factually wrong